for the last six years the Royal Bank of
Scotland has been a major political
headache for the UK government 45 and a
half billion pounds of taxpayers money
was injected into the bank to keep it
afloat in 2008 but now it might just
prove to be an unlikely Ally for the no
campaign in the debate about scottish
independence ahead of next week's
referendum the reason RBS has said that
it will read domicile it's legal
headquarters to England from Scotland in
the event of a yes vote there are sound
reasons for it to do so the views of
credit ratings agencies and the Bank of
England have been taken into account and
there's no doubt that an independent
Scotland would find it hard to sustain
banks of the scale of RBS and lloyds
banking group which is also backed by
taxpayers and has also said that it will
move its legal base to England from
Scotland in the event of independence
coming to pass nor are the big financial
institutions the only ones to be talking
about this major retailers including
next John Lewis and Kingfisher the owner
of being q of warned of the threat of
price rises for consumers in an
independent Scotland because of the
complexity of a supply chain in an
independent country all of this adds up
to something of a political headache for
Alex Salmond the leader of the yes
campaign who has argued vociferously
that an independent Scotland would in
time have a stronger economy but with
uncertainty surrounding the currency
that an independent Scotland would use
it's understandable that banks such as
RBS and Lloyds have said that they need
to do what's in the best interest of
their customers and other stakeholders
and go to the safety first option of
moving their headquarters to England the
battle for the big corporate vote is
still on and it's anyone's guess about
which way other big companies will go in
the coming days